hey everyone this is Meg from pending
and movieclips with things to know
before you see insidious chapter 3 for
example did you know it's scary as hell
and pursues home George the prequel to
insidious and insidious chapter 2
promises to be more terrifying than ever
chapter 3 follows team Quinn played by
Stephanie Scott who seeks to help up
psychic medium Elise Rayner to contact
her mother's spirit also new to the cast
is Dermot Mulroney as Sean Brenner Quinn
still lynce is back as Rayner along with
her cronies Tucker and specks played by
Inga Sampson and Leigh Whannell Linnell
co-create the franchise along with
insidious 1 & 2 director James Vaughn he
also wrote all three films and is making
his directorial debut in Chapter three
'whom was too busy furiously directing
another movie team 1 l and want her
famous for their freaky masked villain
they created the iconic Billy the puppet
from saw continuing that tradition meets
man who can't breathe donning a
breathing mask reminds me of one of my
favorite villains of all time the great
Dennis Hopper at blue velvet don't you
look at me 1l calls the man who can't
breathe cancer personified which in my
opinion is a super original concept and
humanizes the story he disguises himself
as poor Quinn's deceased mother luring
her into the dark world aka the further
in the insidious franchise the further
is basically the astral plane
a world where spirits dwell chapter 3
will take audiences deeper into the
further and shed light on how Raynor was
able to get Josh Lampert there in the
first film another mask I'm hoping to
see is Reiner's crazy world war 2 gas
mask why does she wear it no clue but
it's awesome could be because sometimes
mediums use sensory deprivation to
connect to spirit Rainer is a psychic
medium let me break it down psychics can
predict the future often using crystal
balls or tarot cards mediums can
communicate with the spirits in the
afterlife psychic mediums can do all the
above like a boss I thought Theresa
Caputo I came along I'll a medium is a
psychic medium along with John Edward
I'm sensing something over here
and are known s no one n marks my
husband larsa's hi scientists have been
trying to prove and disprove
supernatural theories for centuries the
facts polls suggest 8 to 20 percent of
people have traveled to the astral plane
and some have come across demonic beings
the truth remains a mystery but who's to
say similar insidious events couldn't
happen to you thanks for watching I'm
Meg from Finnegan movie clips don't
forget to subscribe and go see insidious
chapter 3 and good luck sleeping tonight
[Music]